2016.
CORRESPONDENT MOLLY LINE ISN'T
CARNEGIE, PENNSYLVANIA.
GOOD EVENING.
>> BOTH PARTIES INVESTED HEAVILY
IN THE RACE BUT THE G.O.P. IS
TAKING AN ALL HANDS ON DECK
APPROACH IN AN ATTEMPT TO HOLD
THIS COVETED SEAT.
WITH A FEW HOURS TO GO, THEY
TRUMP FAMILY IS SENDING IN ONE
OF ITS OWN.
REPUBLICANS ARE POURING OUT THE
SUGAR IN PENNSYLVANIA FROM
DONALD TRUMP JR. MAKING A STOP
TODAY.
>> EXCITED TO HAVE SOMEONE
FIGHTING WITH MY FATHER AGAINST
THESE THINGS.
>> THE PRESIDENTIAL FAMILY
PATRIARCH.
>> WE NEED OUR CONGRESSMAN
SACCONE.
>> RICK SACCONE HAS THE FULL
THROATED BACKING OF PARTY AND
PRESIDENT.
>> IF PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN YOUR
CORNER, HOW CAN YOU LOSE?
>> IN A DISTRICT THE
PRESIDENT WON, SACCONE SHOULD
HAVE THE EDGE BUT THE DEMOCRAT
CONOR LAMB HAS SOUGHT TO AVOID
ALIENATING THE FAITHFUL.
HE IS PRO-GUN AND HAS EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THE PRESIDENT'S NEW
TARIFFS.
FORMER VP JOE BIDEN STUMPED FOR
HIM LAST WEEK.
CONOR LAMB HAS EARNED UNIVERSE
SUPPORT -- UNION SUPPORT.
HE VOWED TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
REPUBLICANS ON SOCIAL SECURITY
AND MEDICARE.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE THESE ARE
ENTITLEMENTS OR ANOTHER FORM OF
WELFARE.
>> WHILE HE HAS WORKED TO
DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM MINORITY
LEADER NANCY PELOSI, THE
PRESIDENT HAS DUBBED HIM "LAMB
THE SCHAMA.
>> HE WON'T GIVE ME ONE VOTE.
>> THE RACES IMPOSSIBLE TO
IGNORE.
>> HOME CONOR LAMB IS RUNNING
FOR CONGRESS.
>> WAITRESS JODY KELLY.
>> CONOR LAMB.
SHE IS ABOUT, HEALTH CARE.
IN THIS PROFESSION, YOU NEED
BETTER HEALTH CARE THAN WHAT WE
HAVE NOW.
>> A THIRD-GENERATION COAL
MINERS SAYS HE'S BEHIND SACCONE.
>> WE NEED MORE CONSERVATIVES IN
WASHINGTON TO SUPPORT TRUMP AND
HELP HIM GET HIS AGENDA THROUGH.
>> NATIONALLY THIS RACE IS BEING
WATCHED CLOSELY WITH AN EYE
TOWARD THE MIDTERMS.
THE LOOMING QUESTION IS A
POTENTIAL SACCONE LOSS AND WHAT
IT COULD MEAN FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S PROGRESS GOING
FORWARD.
THE VOTERS HIT THE POLLS